yo what's up guys welcome to the long
awaited episode of stunt memory acts
2023 it's been a while we have not been
on the couch together this is my very
first stman reaction Ren is a special
guest hell yeah Ren I have been trying
to be on this couch for the show for
four years now and I finally get the
chance so I'm excited to show you guys a
clip that I've been really wondering
about
today wait I think they stitched it I
two
jums this is Donnie y being
donen oh across the face I have a clip
from what is deemed perhaps the most
dangerous film ever
made this is stunts only because it's
there's a
camera 70 crew members were
injured I think once you see what the
movie is about you like oh just
[Music]
70 the closer you get to them the more
they'd like you the safe for you'd be
but look yo it's a lion it's a bunch of
lions it's a whole Pride so the guy in
the blue is Noah Marshall who is the
director and writer and producer of this
movie and he acts in it as well dude the
story behind this movie is crazy the
lead actress from the birds Tippy
Henderson and her husband no Marshall
went on a a safari they're like they're
really inspired they're like let's make
a movie about lions and just like what
there's like a house where they're doing
research like Jane Goodall except
instead of monkeys it's lions and
they're like I love that idea let's get
as many many lions as we can to raise
them from Cubs so they're comfortable
around people which by the way this is
in Sherman Oaks at their house uh and
the government was like you can't do
this so they got uh a bit of property up
in solidad Canyon and built this this
Ranch effectively this big cat Ranch so
this is kind of like his mad experiment
right and you can see the actors like
genuinely uncomfortable the scene it's
just playing I'm telling you but you
going get kids the cats got a little EX
no he just dropped not them deciding
they want to jump him hearing him trying
to deliver his lines like these guys are
just playing
around yo they don't know how to go easy
they're just like here you go here's all
190 lbs of me cats as we know if you
have a pet cat are basically fun little
cudly things with razors on the edges of
them so everybody's constantly getting
cut everybody's constantly getting bit
I'm going to tell you more about this
let's just watch a little scene here I
got to go help your uncle are killing
each
other this is insane this is absolutely
insane this is stunts only because it's
there's a
[Laughter]
camera oh you want to go yeah all right
look at his look at his hand now he just
got cut his hand went limp and just dude
that Lion's claw just slaps his hand and
slices it open and you can tell he's
like
ouch like I cut
it's hard to find articles about this
that are like not sensationalized cuz
they're all written as if like lions
attacked and Maul like the Lions aren't
attacking anyone no if the lions were
attacking somebody they'd be dead but
it's you know it is Cinema they're
Faking It the lions are playing rough
housing they're not they're not trying
to eat how how you would play with your
dog right exactly you're just it's
you're just dealing with the natural
consequences of being in close
proximities with the lion the Director
of Photography is yand deont really the
man who directed Speed and speed to no
way he got scalped by a l movie he get
hit you get so he they they had a scene
where he dug a hole with the camera
where he wanted all the lines to run by
yeah and so they filmed the scene with
the lines going by and he turns to get
the shot cuz he's he's the kind of guy
who gets the shot right and's like
what's
that and scalps the entire back of his
head it's all hanging forwards he had to
go to the hospital and get it all
stitched back on oh my God and it's
experiences like that that made the man
that shot Speed 2 cruise control where
they crashed a boat into an actual fake
town we we saw that when Jordan Allen
brought in on VFX reactor like what kind
of man would ever do something this
insane it's like oh the kind of man who
shot a movie with 150 lines God that
many l it's like it makes a lot of sense
now on one hand this is such a unique
Gem of a movie on the other hand it's
really
irresponsible really kind of it probably
didn't feel like they were exploiting
animals but at the same time it is
exploitation of animals 100% but at the
same time the director is the one there
in the shot too so it's like it's one
thing to be like I have a crazy idea you
go do it right other be like I have a
crazy idea I'm going to go do it do it I
have a crazy idea follow me yeah exactly
maybe I can admire the dedication while
still not admiring the ways in which it
was done execution yeah yeah so you
would would you consider this stunt work
um no I would not consider this
hazardous work this is is out of my
wheelhouse don't call me so this is like
these actors are just it's a full send
every shot it's like I'm full sending
even though I'm just standing next to a
tiger I'm just like at all times I'm
worried that's so much stress and
anxiety honestly I think they're lucky
no one died they are I would say they're
lucky that the lion that one of the
Lions didn't flip that switch and go
into your food mode what's up guys and
welcome back to producers react to great
and ready to eat meals today's sponsor
is meals our box just arrived and it's
lunch time so I'm going to heat one up
and tell you a little bit more about it
so I'm going with the jalapeno lime
cheddar chicken bowl this is bring going
to be super easy to microwave and ready
to go while that's cooking I'm going to
tell you a little bit more about Factor
meals on a weekly basis here at Corridor
we produce a ton of content that we are
constantly working on and there's not a
lot of time outside of that so Factory
meals is a perfect meal service because
they meal prep your meals delivered
right to your door not to mention Factor
meals are designed by chefs and
dietitians that means they're not only
delicious but they're nutritious there's
over 34 choices weekly for you to choose
from you can upgrade to Gourmet plus and
they offer protein shakes and smoothies
that are also delivered you can add more
than just meals to your package that
means you can skip the extra grocery
trip you can skip the meal prep Factory
meals are fresh never Frozen ready to go
in 2 minutes you just heat them up and
you get right back to achieving your
goals what else is there to say who
doesn't want conveniently delivered to
your door meals ready to go for whenever
you're in a pinch or you just want to
get on top of your nutrition goals I'm
going to eat this l right now but if you
want to get on board too you can go to
factor 75 or just hit that link in the
description below but use the code
Corridor 50 and you'll get 50% off your
first box great food ready to go for 50%
off what's not to love just hit that
link in description make sure you use
that promo code now let's get back to
[Applause]
reaction have you guys seen Ted lasso of
course yeah all three seasons oh wow
okay so this is from season 2 episode 9
when beard goes on his his crazy uh uh
tour through the night as they
[Music]
say nowhere to go so then this scene
came out of nowhere I remember being
like ha haa beard wait that is
[Music]
[Applause]
beard oh wow I think beard was on wires
but I think there's a transition at the
end to an effect shot or a stunt person
I think they stitched it I don't see jum
I think there's two jumps I've seen
somebody do a similar test having a
performer perform this stunt two ways
and they're able to match how the arms
were moving I think the transition is
right as it come out of slow motion if
you watch his face really carefully I
feel like the beard disappears right at
the last second just a little bit right
now that's du guy yeah wow that's an
expert transition wow the body
transition was Flawless it was it was
really well done
I that's the stuntman they're just that
good the stuntman able to be like that's
how he moved his arms that's how okay
cool got it yep got the little flow at
the hands so but like that actual fall
though is he on wires and descending or
is he actually dropping I'd say they put
him on descenders cuz it looks like he's
falling full speed yeah so what happens
even when you get put on the descender
they descend you for a certain amount of
the speed and then they treat it as if
you're still jumping from 10 ft so
they'll descend it to that amount of
speed for you and then let you just drop
10 ft okay it's like a speed limiter
exactly I love this show first off I
love this show and this scene just came
out of nowhere it was like haha oh wow
crazy stunt right what it's the perfect
use of like let's not go too ambitious
let's keep it really straightforward
it's a ones shot moment and because a
onshot moment ends up being really
compelling and really like visceral
feeling you're going to die maybe
not John Wick we haven't spoken about
this we haven't spoken about John Wick
before I think maybe maybe it's because
I'm like hoping that we can eventually
get like Chad on the couch I think we
can so I want to start with just I I was
like let's do a little
bit this is donen being donen he's
playing this character named Kane who's
blind and you kind of get a gist of how
badass this character
is man he's so fast how is Donan still
so limber how old is he he's like in his
50s yeah he's still very fast but a lot
of what's making fast is like he's doing
small movements and the stun guys are
really selling the hits and they're
doing Rapid Fire Hits like when this guy
gets hit in the face with a sword D Yen
just kind of Wiggles his hands like this
you know the guy really sells it and he
sells it fast he's whipping his head
back and
forth is there any like purpose to that
type of kick I feel like that would be
really hard on your knee it's an axe
kick he's using it I guess as a
exclamation mark similar to like Bruce's
Stomp
I mean it would hurt your knee if you
don't do it right I feel like now I've
watched it a couple times I feel like
he's actually landing on the bottom of
his foot as opposed to his heel right
he's flat footing and he's being nice
you would actually hit somebody with the
heel
though give a little give him a little
flash point like they gave everything
that donen is known for doing in this
fight they gave him a piece of all of it
right the big wi up the thing we know
from itman is the rapid punches he does
all of it all bow connects it all
together which is really fun that's
choreographing to your your your star to
your actor who's performing and the
overlap into what's basically wrestling
characters with these actors is funny
and strange but in a good way like the
fact they have signature moves and they
have these attitudes these characters
they play and even like like here's my
finisher the people's elbow you know
this is his people's elbow exactly right
R you should see the whole film and then
we can talk when we get Chad here we'll
talk more in depth of all the crazy STS
that they did in this movie cuz it's
literally an action film like it's just
a buffet all for one and
for there's been something that's been
living in my head Nico something that
bothered me as a kid I want to see if we
can debunk it right here on the show
today oh sweet awesome the musketeer has
his final fight scene let's look at this
ladder
fight oh that man just floated so like
the movie turns in kind of woo pish it
turns into woja kind of I sense
wirework
oh man waa yo I feel like it'd be so
easy to just slip when you're landing on
something like that and your foot just
goes through the ladder perfectly
balanced that's not exactly how balance
works but even if you're fighting your
mortal enemy by this point in the fight
You' be like hold up bro this is crazy
what we're doing is crazy is it and
they' be like yeah this is
Bonkers just look at each other like
sick all right let's get back this is
really cool
for some reason I feel like I've seen
this fight before or something very
close to this fight before and I think
it's in Once Upon A Time In China just
let's watch let's see okay okay
okay all right here we go am I a
musketeer wao they split the ladder heck
yes wo that's cool climbing the ladder
while it's like still falling
over skape move wait I'm sure they're on
wires oh I actually saw a wire there in
one shot you did yeah right there see I
did see it I never realized how much
wire workk is in in old martial arts
films like I'd see stuff that's like
this is crazy there's no way they did
that stunt it's like little by little
starting to realize there's magic tricks
in every shot and there is real stunts
and danger but it's more that there's
like it's physically demanding stuff
it's things where you have to be
physically trained for it right I mean
it's safe to say that the musketeer was
definitely inspired by this fight yes
the question is how speci right I'm
waiting to see a balance beam ladder
fight right that's why I'm like I feel
like there is a balance beam little
seesaw
action
seesaw oh here it is oh wow but it's
like a freaking
T it's just inspired by yeah you know
what I'll give musketeer just a simple
good homage yeah yeah I don't feel like
it ripped this off it'd be very hard to
rip this off that's true like if they
can rip this off like ah whatever Kudos
good
job
you just did one of the hardest scenes
in stun work but yeah so that was it it
was debunked it turns out that the
musketeer was inspired by it didn't
fully just rip off one of my favorite
Hong Kong films thanks for thanks for
doing that with me Nico this is
delightful this has been one of my
favorite movies for some reason for some
reason for some reason it just it it
stays rentree in my head Last Samurai is
a good movie yeah it's a great movie Tom
Cruz man man Tom Cruz and this is like
the son of the guy who he killed so this
is like the kid's opportunity to beat
his ass right this is like Revenge
time kid's going though he just catches
it like just just like we're play this
is supposed to be sword fighting and
here you are grabbing the blade and then
it's like word somebody your own size I
love this actor here he's so good I love
this
guy jeez went straight for the
ribs o across the face like that would
probably that would take you out for the
rest of the
day he what's the trick to selling pain
on camera like if you get punched you're
like ah not not telling the hit but like
the pain afterwards showing the effect
of it right right if you watch like an
MMA fight when somebody gets punched
they're not
like like right like Jackie makes faces
he's like
ah what about the emotion in the face so
like if you so let's say you have to
sell it with an expression like and
you're like well do you go the
jackiechan route of going or like what
is the way to do that well it depends on
the character so his character for
instance he's supposed to be a soldier
so he shows that he's in pain but then
he has to show that he is going to
overcome it so you show the oh that hurt
and then the I can't show you that hurt
though so it's the same with feeling of
anger or emotion and not being allowed
to show it most people when they cry
they don't want you to see them cry you
know like they imely wipe it away they
don't just let the one tear drop like we
see in all the movies it's like I'm so
immediately I'm going show it for a
moment but then I have to get back into
my strength not show that you hint at it
you don't go full Jacky though you have
to go like quarter Jackie and then pull
it away from everybody ways that you do
it without showing like the facial
expression is through body language
which we see when he goes for the ribs
for the first time you see that aspect
well also his performance here like
evolves over the course of the scene he
gets slower and more tired to the point
at the end he's like barely even like
throwing it but he's still trying
exactly and that's where he pulls our
heartstrings here this is how he wins
over everybody including the audience as
this man who is fighting these demons
along with having to be a captive and
earn the respect of the people around
them and that's like one of the biggest
things that I care about when it comes
to seeing a fight scene is how does it
push us forward in the story or make us
care about the character yeah cuz
especially in this movie where later on
this pays off when he becomes an expert
and is able to fend off an entire Squad
right this is the start of that whole
training montage that leads to him being
able to withstand 14 15 strikes and
they're betting on him you know make
sure you guys subscribe to card
digital.com where you can see an
extended version of the stuntman reacts
episode that was great me you are a
professional oh thanks brother it's been
a while since we've done a stunt react
episode it's nice to be back just kind
of looking at Clips leave a comment down
below for any cool stunts you want us to
break down or ask other stunt people
their opinion on them we'd love to do so
well thanks for watching everyone and
maybe I'll see you in the next stman
react episode as well peace